-Guys, this year is the 50th
anniversary of "Sesame Street."
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
50 years? That's crazy.
-I know.
I've always wanted to visit
"Sesame Street."
-Uh, you do know
how to get there, right?
-[ Scoffs ] Sure, I do.
-Okay. How?
How do you get to Sesame Street?
-Well, it's how the words go.
Sunny day,
sweeping the clouds away.
On my way to where
the air is sweet.
I guess those aren't
really directions.
-Oh, Elmo can tell you
how to get there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Elmo! My goodness!
You can t--
You can get me there?!
-Yeah. Come on. Come on.
The bus is waiting! Come on!
-Oh, let's go. Let's go.
Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is this the --
Is this the local
or the express?
-Uh, it's -- it's just a bus.
Okay, buckle up, everybody!
Let's go to Sesame Street!
-Okay.
♪ Can you tell me how to get ♪
-♪ How to get to Sesame Street ♪
-To get to Sesame Street,
you don't need a GPS.
You can watch on HBO
or check it out on PBS.
I can tell you how to get there
with some help from my friends.
Then you'll never have to ask
yourself that question again.
-Because you know.
-♪ Before we go much further ♪
♪ I just wanted to say ♪
♪ That this rap is brought to
you by the letters T and J ♪
-♪ Now just keep your eyes open,
and if you're feeling lucky ♪
♪ you might bump
into a pair of friends ♪
♪ Who own a rubber ducky ♪
♪ Just look at all the friendly
faces smile wherever we go ♪
-♪ Our motto is the more,
the merrier, mi amigo ♪
-♪ We're on the right path,
and we keep getting closer ♪
-♪ But you can get there quicker
with the help of Super Grover ♪
-♪ It's a pretty long journey,
so you might need to rest ♪
♪ You can take a power nap ♪
♪ Up in Big Bird's nest ♪
-Slumber party!
-♪ I'm blanking on the address
of the place I wanna be ♪
♪ What's the number
of the house? ♪
-♪ That's 1-2-3! ♪
-♪ Can you tell me how to get ♪
♪ How to get to Sesame Street ♪
-♪ What's the matter, guys?
You look a little lost ♪
-♪ Elmo tries to
avoid Grouchland at
any and all costs ♪
-♪ How's it going, Oscar? Well,
I guess we'll see ya later ♪
-♪ Even though he's a Grouch,
he's a really good neighbor ♪
-Scram!
-♪ This is great ♪
♪ There's so many
different people to meet ♪
♪ Are there any other friends
who live on Sesame Street? ♪
-♪ Ladies and gentlemen,
the best rapper around ♪
♪ Here's Tariq from The Roots
with the Sesame breakdown ♪
-♪ Grover, Bert and Ernie,
Zoe, Elmo, Rosita ♪
♪ Gordon, Susan, Bob, Linda,
Luis, Maria ♪
♪ Betty Lou, Little Jerry,
Julia, Gabi ♪
♪ Snuffy, Telly, Biff,
and Sully, Abby Cadabby ♪
♪ Amazing Mumford, Prairie Dawn,
Count von Count ♪
♪ Herry Monster, Baby Bear ♪
♪ Oscar the Grouch ♪
-[ Grumbles ]
-♪ Frazzle, Gladys, Don Music,
Hoots is an owl ♪
♪ Forgetful Jones, and Lefty
trying to sell you a vowel ♪
♪ Barkley, Big Bird,
Cookie Monster, and Guy Smiley ♪
♪ Natasha,
the Two-Headed Monster ♪
♪ Yip Yips and Slimey ♪
-Boy, that was a lot names!
Does Tariq need
a glass of water?
-No, I'm good. Thanks.
-Okay.
-♪ Now I think I get it,
what you're trying to say ♪
♪ It's not about directions
but the friends along the way ♪
-Yeah!
-Happy 50th, Sesame Street!
Stay gold!
-♪ Actually, Mr. Fallon,
I'm only 6 years old ♪
Everybody!
-♪ Sunny days
sweeping the clouds away ♪
-♪ The clouds away ♪
-♪ On my way to where
the air is sweet ♪
♪ Can you tell me how to get ♪
♪ How to get to Sesame Street ♪
-So that's...
-♪ How to get to Sesame Street ♪
-Now you know...
-♪ How to get to
Sesame Str-e-e-e-eet ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was really great!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
♪♪